- loans for a pretty good afternoon
again everyone
sousou's ECP would me up I'm here to
give you some information
about the college meeting the college
has decided to record to register to
European citizens initiatives starting
with eat original unmask your food the
goal of which is to have an obligatory a
mandatory declaration of origin for all
fruits to protect public health prevent
fraud and in guarantee the right to
consumer information the second
initiative is entitled halt stop fraud
and her use of the European Union funds
and will have stricter controls in the
Member States they do not take part in
the European public prosecutor's office
in order to prevent in order to protect
the union's financial interests let me
to remind you that in both cases the
decision taken by the Commission just
regards the legal the legal receive
ability of the the legal admissible 'ti
of the two proposals we have two press
releases ready for you with more
information you can find them on our
website beside it three senior
management appointments to the positions
of director namely for mr. Johan Berlin
in the director-general for budgets Mr
Bandt Adolphe in the Director General
for human resources and security and mr.
Philip Labonte in the joint research
center congratulations to all three of
them and then finally commissioner I
think I reported to the College on the
progress made towards achieving the
target of at least 40% female
representation among Commission
management by the end of the term of the
current Commission as you may remember
reaching this target was what I was is
one of the personal commitments that
resident Younker made at the beginning
of this method so in light of this I'm
happy to announce to you that the
proportion of female managers in the
Commission accounted for 39% of all
managers up from 30% at the beginning of
November 2014 when this Commission took
office and this progress comes after
series of measures which the Commission
has put in place and I think it also one
of those examples to show that this
commission keeps its promises most
importantly it will ensure that our
management in the Commission is more
diverse more balanced and better
reflects the realities in European
society so these are the items that I
wanted to share with you if you have any
question before we switch to the
technical briefing please fire ahead
otherwise let's switch to the
asia-europe connectivity technical
briefing I see one hand yes yes go ahead